retirer la viande des assiettes des
élèves julien de normandie n'y est pas
vraiment favorable ce mardi le ministre
de l'agriculture a parlé de honte
concernant la décision de grégory douce
et le maire europe ecologie les verts de
lieux qui peut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui
dans les cantines de la république on
arrête de servir de la viande tous les
jours de la semaine
évidemment moi je ne le comprends pas
mais comme beaucoup beaucoup de parents
d'élèves
il y a une position qui est une posture
d'une municipalité europe ecologie les
verts qui consiste à arrêter de servir
de la viande à nos enfants
et c'est aberrant d'un point de vue
nutritionnel et c'est une honte d'un
point de vue social si cette position
est partagée par le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin qui samedi
avait été le premier membre du
gouvernement a dénoncé une idéologie
scandaleuse et une politique moraliste
et élitiste des verts qui exclut les
classes populaires
ce n'est en revanche pas le cas de la
ministre de la transition écologique
lundi barbara pompili a regretté un
débat préhistorique
je regrette beaucoup que sur ce sujet on
retombe dans un débat préhistorique et
des clichés éculés du type
l'alimentation végétarienne serait une
alimentation déséquilibrée
alors qu'on sait que la viande peut être
remplacé par du poisson des oeufs des
légumineuses qui apporte toutes les
protéines nécessaires
malgré ces renvois de balle successifs
et ses divergences importantes julien de
normandie à ce mardi réfuté toute
cacophonie au sein du gouvernement
le maire de lyon qui explique le choix
d'un menu unique sans viande par le
nouveau protocole sanitaire et la
nécessité de fluidifier le service à la
cantine pourrait avoir du mal à apaiser
les tensions
parallèlement à la fronde des
agriculteurs qui ont manifesté lundi
dans la métropole rhodanienne et des
parents d'élèves ont décidé de déposer
une requête en référé devant le tribunal
administratif de lyon
il demande un minimum de menus avec de
la viande dans la semaine